[Music]
inflation inflation inflation it's like
that you know those old car commercials
price down you know i feel like i feel
like that's
in there yeah it's like inflation is
everywhere and it is at all time highs
uh and yet george what's interesting
about this is that we're also in a
season of life in america where incomes
are up but because inflation is so high
in some cases it's a net net meaning
you're not getting ahead uh you've got
some you've got some current news and
data on this yeah so what's going on
we're gonna do a series helping you guys
out with what we call your four walls so
this is food utilities housing and
transportation those are the big ones
that people are worried about right now
so we're going to start with food today
give you guys some quick tips now these
aren't you know life-changing hacks
they're going to save you hundreds of
dollars but it can't help to avoid you
feeling that pinch every time you go to
the grocery store all right so let's
jump in here uh we did a state of
personal finance study and we found that
groceries have jumped about eight
percent which tracks with inflation here
and the average cost of monthly
groceries for one person went from 223
to 410 and for a family of four it
shoots up to 863 dollars now a lot of
you are going oh my gosh that's it or oh
my gosh that much you know what the data
doesn't cover uh the coleman household
where i have two teenage boys that's
like three extra people that's true the
amount of groceries i got those boys can
eat i've seen them one pack of bacon gum
gun in one morning well that brings me
to my first tip here ken we gotta shop
at the cheapest grocery store there it
is a lot of people they have their
grocery store and you can't you can't
get ken coleman away from publix you
know everyone's got their groceries i'm
a kroger guy wow yeah i wouldn't take it
for a kroger guy really shopping's a
pleasure at publix i know you're a man
of leisure and pleasure that's a tag
line i'm all about convenience and
there's one in the neighborhood oh that
makes sense that makes sense well aldi
is one of the best grocery stores this
is not sponsored but they just happen to
have great prices my parents shop
exclusively at aldi they carry on about
how they save money they're retired they
get it it's simple it's no frills you
got to pay for a bag you got to put a
quarter in the cart i mean they they're
they're making sure that they're able to
give you those low prices in different
ways so aldi i love trader joe's for
their prices uh walmart can be great
costco can be great if you do it right
now costco can be a danger zone when you
get four things and it costs you nine
thousand dollars because you tried the
rice peel off sample and just had to
have a four pound bag well who doesn't
need a six pack of polish kibasa
you know what i mean you can't just buy
one pack i'm here for that yeah so
choosing a cheaper grocery store for
right now you don't have to go to whole
foods we can go to aldi and get the same
thing uh just might not be the name
brand you know go generic go with the
store brand you'll be okay big generic
brand guy number two i want you to look
for foods that give you more bang for
your buck so we talk a lot about beans
and rice here never has it been more
true beans and rice rice and beans it's
one of the cheapest staple foods and
it's filling yeah let me tell you
something bow tie pasta i've been giving
real life coleman house hacks as you go
along bow tie pasty you could buy six
boxes for a dollar forty six
unbelievable get those carbs rice pastas
those are cheap get some sauce yeah
pasta's cheap and uh buying your meat in
bulk as meat is getting expensive here
so uh there's one right there number two
number three actually cut out the wants
and only buy the items you need
no frivolous chocolate chip cookies are
getting thrown in the cart ken oh it's
tough what is the actual food that is
going to sustain our family i really
like ice cream and i can make a case
that it sustains my mental health well
we're going store brand and we're going
to get the full gallon to save yeah on
coffee well i'm all about the gallon of
ice cream there you go yeah there's your
hat ken so make sure that you're you
know you're talking with your spouse if
you've got one about the grocery budget
and looking for ways that we can cut
things out and making sure nothing
frivolous gets added to that list
now lastly ken this is one that you
probably don't do but cashback apps yeah
i don't even know what that means i'm a
fan so there's apps like they're called
ibotta fetch rewards there's one called
checkout51 receipt hog and what you do
receipt hog yes if i was gonna be into
one that would be the one that i was
that i would just based on the names
just like i could tell my friends on the
phone yeah i got this new app or a seat
hog that's fun to say
i don't know who your friends are but i
hope they enjoy it oh you actually do
so here's they're simple you uh upload
your receipt and you'll get cash back
for certain items you buy really tell
you you know what about my ice cream i
get cash back on my uncertain brands
now here's the catch i don't want you to
buy the name brand ice cream that's two
dollars more to save a dollar when you
could have got the generic brand so
still shop wisely
only shop what's in your budget uh but
it could it could help you get some
money back if you spend 80 bucks you
might get five 10 bucks back that helps
every little bit goes a long way so
remember actual paper coupons remember
these ken i took these on sundays with
my dad growing up oh yeah big fan of the
paper coupon a lot of them have gone
digital now yeah but all of these take
an extra step it takes a little bit more
uh research it takes a little bit more
patience and diligence to make sure that
before you impulsively walk through the
grocery store and then get mad that
prices are high you go in with a list
you go in with a budget you go in with a
plan and you go in willing to make some
sacrifices in order to save some money
is there a rule of thumb george on how
much a person could save let's say
you've got a
uh let's say you're going to go spend
200 bucks as your budget or 300 bucks at
the grocery store can you how much of
that could you save
ooh
i'm going to go if you can chase paper
or digital coupons i think if you can
shave off five or ten percent of each
purchase i'm calling that a win so i've
seen these stories like where people get
their entire thing for free that's not
that's not real well you can do that but
you're not going to be able to survive
off of that because you can't drink thai
detergent
well you can it's just not good for you
the kids are doing it the kids are doing
all kinds of stupid so you know you know
what i mean though you're not gonna you
can't do that with so ten percent five
to ten percent is a realistic and so all
of a sudden i mean which is the amount
of inflation we're seeing yeah so it
combats that if you can save eight
percent and inflation's eight percent
it's net zero yeah so there's some quick
tips for you all i know it's there's no
easy hack i wish i could give you some
amazing news but it really just takes
some diligence some sacrifice and some
research in order to get through these
strange times when we're seeing
groceries up eight percent but also
let's not get crazy it's eight percent
so if it was you know a dollar now it's
a dollar eight
we're not talking three four five
dollars more for that same thing and
this goes with eating out too see now
okay now george this is why you are a
ramsey personality a thought leader and
you're winning this space because you
just said math well because here's the
deal
you would you make a very good point on
the eight percent and you put it in real
dollars and cents
all right
people freak out because that's all we
get fed or negative headlines right the
sky is not falling no it you know like
because i i
i hear the stories too
and i'm like well i mean and again i
really i'm not making a joke i have two
athlete boys in my house that are
16 and 13. my 16 year old is a man child
i mean i eat a side of beef he's twice
my size and i'm a grown man yeah i need
to get longhorns in the backyard that's
the kind of rate of which we are going
through protein i'm serious so we've
seen our bill jump
but at the same time it's not like the
end of the world a little bit of
discipline a little bit of budgeting and
you can you can make your way through
this yeah well our plan works in good
times and bad and so times of inflation
you go all right we have margin on our
budget because that's how we live our
lives we live on less than we make we
have an emergency fund we don't have
debt and therefore all that money can go
towards helping us survive inflation and
so that's what i want to remind people
is follow these steps do this plan
because it works and you know i was just
talking to my neighbor yesterday and
we're complaining about gas prices oh of
course i just got an electric car and so
here here's what she therefore and she
said you know what at the end of the day
i'm grateful because i can actually
afford it it's not fun but i can afford
it and that level of contentment that's
something that we need to have as a
society and go hey listen i'm not going
to be bankrupted by grocery prices yeah
and so there's a lot of people out there
who are really really hurting and i have
a lot of empathy for those people but
for most americans this is just a man
that stinks
gas is a hundred bucks to fill up
instead of 50. yeah same deal we'll get
back to the that we talk about when you
know where your money's going a budget
is a plan that tells your money where to
go then you can weather this